if you have an insecurity with that
that's on you finish let me finish
because you're not let me finish let me
finish but can she finish who gives up
about a woman it's useless right
I'm just saying maybe if you cared a
little bit about her finishing you
wouldn't have to worry about what's
going on on IG because you piping her
down
all right by uh popular demand
appearance here's committed relationship
you saw the clip I thought it clipped
out of him on the show so I decided to
go watch the the full thing because I
was like what's going on here okay and
this is the truth for people who didn't
watch the full thing they just saw the
clip on Instagram whatever people hate
fresh and fit so much they want to see
them fail that's it that's really it
because if you watch the full one I want
to be honest with you the interviewers
look terrible fresh and fit looked
terrible but the way the clip is edited
it just makes the fashion fit look
terrible man it's capable of having sex
with other women while Still Loving his
girl the same you're actually saying
that in a relationship it's okay for men
to go and explore other options but we
have to be happy with you and not
explore options absolutely close on your
end open on my end and I think this
should be honest between the two why did
anyone agree to that you can't just get
throwing that thing around I spoke I
spoke today I spoke to Dan I spoke to
Dan belzerian yeah I'm sick of you
asking to finish your long boring
answers that are the same answer every
time we ask you a question even Dan
Bilzerian last week told me to my face
so [ __ ] what clown here you are on
the show I can turn you off as well just
turn these clowns off see you fellas
Grow Up Ring us back when you're 30 and
you've got a half a brain you're not
running around being led by your own
dicks bye-bye see you later turn I
well if you're in a serious committed
relationship with a guy and you have you
know sexy photos of yourself on the
internet you know Instagram is just one
medium that you can do it yeah it is
cheating can a man be on Instagram in a
relationship but not a woman
it's it's not the same why but does it
depend on the
contentless on Instagram like versus
women I say women want typically
unlimited security from the best man
that they can get versus men want to get
the most women they can get even a man
that's extremely good looking is not
going to get nearly the amount of
options that a woman that's mediocre are
you kidding
you know you know what I told you like
feminists and these guys are just two
sides of the same coin
about the same side right
so his argument for why the men can keep
the Instagram as men and women aren't
the same
women if they got Instagram they're
gonna get way more responses you know
without even trying he acknowledges that
men sometimes get responses but it's not
even close and so because of that men
and women aren't the same therefore my
argument makes sense
it's the exact same argument that women
use to be able to be violent against men
men and women aren't the same I'm
physically weaker than the average man
so I could slap the [ __ ] out of you
because I don't do as much damage it's
the exact same logic
it is they're still getting hit on by
the same effect to the old not Club
rules let's go back to the nightclub if
you were at the nightclub and the boys
have talked about this on the Freshman
fit podcast boys will line up and will
stand there for ages so I'm going to
show you something real quick I want you
guys to pay attention because I think
Myron doesn't realize he does this but
he was like can I finish can I finish
can I finish but he's the one because he
cuts people off all the time on the
screen right here we have uh a chart
from OkCupid and this illustrates that
even the most attractive men in the
light blue are not even compete are
barely competing against girls in the
mid-range men and women are not the same
time
and he's in a relationship is that
cheating
no no because it's not the same at all
it's different I know why it's different
guys listen as guys we zoom in on the
girls photos we zoom in
your issues I mean let me let me break
this down for y'all okay you should have
said
guys guys guys guys guys guys guys guys
guys let me let me break it down first
so let's let's let's uh Jackie let me
let me ask you a question what is your
dream card my dream car yes your dream
car
probably driving I'll drive a Range
Rover I love it so let's go let's go
into a scenario here okay
all right and just let me finish let me
finish this concept guys let me get
something okay so let's say you go to
the uh to the dealership and you buy a
brand new Range Rover okay Range Rover
Sport you've been wanting it for a while
sign the paperwork pay the money buy it
cash you're good to go drive it off the
lot you don't care about it losing value
whatever this is your dream card let's
get back to your house two weeks later
okay the uh the car dealer comes back to
your place says Hey listen man kind of
showing our cars uh we're gonna need to
put it for sale sign on your car and a
couple days a week we're gonna just need
to put on display back at the dealership
and you know one or two people might
test drive it are you okay
answer the question how would that make
you feel well obviously I wouldn't be
okay with that okay thank you that's
exactly how men feel when they're women
post sexy photos of themselves on the
internet to advertise to other men
because women men are territorial with
their women it's been that way since the
beginning
a man that's gonna put a six-pack or a
man that's gonna put like a gray
sweatpants I mean how is that different
though
will men are territorial
woman aren't listen men and women are
different
men are different we're not equal
yeah but that's not what we're talking
about that's what he's talking about
yeah I understand but you need to talk
to him not to me I understand that no no
stop looking at me to make a counter
argument like yo [ __ ] Defenders right
from East Africa right and we shaved but
he's balding okay don't be we in the
same boat I still got my head I'm good
hey I don't hey okay okay
I don't get emotional I'm like no I just
today's video is brought to you by our
sponsorship
and you know what I'm actually gonna
call them and see if they want to
sponsor this video let's get this money
listen Myron's angry and I understand
why he suffers from extremely smooth
skin on the top of his Cranium okay when
you're balding that's tough it's even
tougher when people notice because the
Skin's so smooth and I want you to have
skin as smooth as Myron's bald spot with
today's sponsor t.h Henley I get
compliments on my skin all the time
people will be asking what's your
skincare routine how do you get your
skin and for a lot of fellas talking
about skin care is a little bit awkward
because either we're too ashamed to do
it or it seems a little bit too feminine
but the truth is having rough skin or
having all these little dents everywhere
isn't some that you necessarily want
especially if it's things that you can
easily avoid through very very good
products I recommend going through that
process and that's where tiege Hanley
comes in they got a great system in
place where you can use their products
to achieve your skin care goal I
personally recommend that you start with
the level one system which comes with
all the basics a daily face wash which
gets rid of all the dirt and Grime on
your face then got it two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of all the
dead skin cells and an AM moisturizer
with SPF 20 because we all need to make
sure that our skin is protected from the
Sun and the cool thing about Tia Shanley
is all their boxes come with
instructions in addition to amazing skin
members of th Henley get tons of
benefits like at least 20 off retail
price the ability to pause or cancel
anytime as well as free us shipping and
because Tia Shanley sponsoring today's
video if you go to the link in the
description below not only will you get
all the benefits that I just listed but
you'll also get a free gift with your
purchase rub out that face so you can
actually start looking fresh
and post what we want if you have an
insecurity with that that's on you if
I'm gonna give you my last name you
cannot go out there and embarrass me I
mean I honestly wouldn't worry too much
about my girl embarrassing me when I run
a podcast called Fresh and fit and I
embarrass myself all the time I mean you
got this goober fresh posted new videos
with Miranda the sugar baby oh you saw
that and now they're back together
you guys give yourselves L all the time
mine was out here probably proclaiming
like who gives a [ __ ] about a woman's
orgasm like it don't matter if you come
like it's not important doesn't matter
in fact I would argue any woman you
marry is literally gonna have her social
status reduced women sometimes feel the
same way we could be in a relationship
with a man who's gorgeous and he's
posting shirtless Tops on Instagram and
we feel like oh that you know you that's
a thirst trap right you're wanting
attention so why is it different I don't
you just think it's okay for a guy to do
it but not okay for a girl to do it
because you're territorial we can be
territorial too because men and women
are different
well women can be territorial
men and women are different I think I
get it now here's the thing you're
you're you're letting your feelings
right get in the way I'm not
understanding I'm not I'm thinking
rationally I'm really not can I please
finish my point
[Laughter]
women can be extremely territorial
instead of responding to what she said
you're like yeah you're just an
emotional crazy [ __ ] who's on her
period and you know females can't think
logically she made a very logical point
and you didn't answer and there's this
this is the idea right the dudes like
these Alpha guys say a lot women are
emotional you know they can't think
logically right look at look at them
look at them they get upset they get a
little bit triggered and we say they're
emotional guys you are aware that pride
and arrogance is also an emotion when
you're sitting there absolutely tone
deaf not being capable of listening to
the person because of your own pride and
arrogance that's also an emotion sure it
doesn't Express outwardly like [ __ ]
neuroticism or yelling or anything like
that but absolutely it is and let's not
pretend like you're the most emotionless
person's [ __ ] staying stoic all the
time we're better than you [ __ ] we are
better than you [ __ ] period huh you
come on bro get the [ __ ] out of here
that's a really really a pass passive
aggressive
not really because I see what you're
doing I see right through it but go
ahead with all the respect [ __ ] your
feelings this is your feelings
she got triggered about that
but because because it was it was it was
with all due respect like I get you're
in your feelings when you're making
money but [ __ ] your feelings like you're
not addressing what she's saying no it's
not what it's not what she said at all
that's what the the reason why she got I
can't understand why she got triggered
because it was because it was what
that's not even
no it's not what we're talking about so
but hey alpha males you know I mean they
know how to say [ __ ] your feelings your
feelings don't matter only mine and my
pride to my arrogance but we can't get
it through their [ __ ] heads your
value is not determined by some [ __ ]
stop thinking that your value is
determined by some [ __ ] [ __ ] guys if
we get these [ __ ] demonetized I don't
care [ __ ] the [ __ ] the world
determines your value based on the value
that you bring to it man hey man you're
sounding very like feelings and
emotional right now can you please
comment down he's territorial it's a
kind of a concern the way you view
relationships like you have ownership of
women yeah that's kind of how it's
coming across when do we say we own
women yeah hold up
didn't they just give it a full two
minute [ __ ] analogy about how they
got a car and now their cars being put
up by the dealership you know the
woman's the car
you bought and paid for her
that's how you guys talk about your
significant others and your women being
on Instagram you use analogy
the thing is is you're saying a guy can
post sexy photos and he can do that in a
relationship
yes men and women are not the same so
from your perspective you say the males
want quantity over quality so if you're
getting attention on Instagram yeah
you're more likely to message them back
you're more likely exactly to act on it
that's a good point
okay
[Laughter]
she made a great point but the thing is
is that women rarely message men that's
not the point oh the point man she's
definitely laid it up very easily
but here's the thing right
and I think this is what makes people
really not like top and admired or they
don't like these conversations or they
find it frustrating because he doesn't
engage with the other person you know
what it's like when you talk with these
dude you ever have issues with your bank
card then you call and it's just an
automated machine and you want to talk
to customer service but it's just a
[ __ ] on the other line being like press
two
to understand your credit balance I want
to talk to you because you start
pressing zero zero zero it's not you
wanna chop your [ __ ] phone I have one
one time one of them uh automated
machines that one time I press zero and
it said that was not of the choices and
then repeated what I said like yeah but
none of your choices are what I want to
do and it kept on repeating and then
what at the end you know I tried that
five times you know what it did yeah I
hung up
that's what it's like to talk to you
kicked me off you hit him up people like
hey so what do you think about the fact
that you know yes men may not have as
much access but them still having access
is still a form of cheating unless your
degree still soap
thank you for calling fresh and fish
that's what it's like bro
and you know what watching this dude do
this argumentation you can tell that he
works from a conclusion and then Works
backwards meaning you you have a thesis
and then you should start to find
evidence that supports them yeah find
anything that helps you and ignore
anything that contradicts you and
whenever you do something like that he's
either gonna be like gonna backtrack
back pedal or that
or well let me finish and then try to
redirect what he was previously saying
into something else like I said like it
was a half only half well according to
your data yeah they're still you're
still getting messaged so let's say I'm
getting message by can I just make one
can you just let me finish the question
you should let me finish I I just want
to make one point so if I'm on Instagram
and I'm getting 40 DMS and you're
getting 20. that's very simple that's
very simple can you believe it
she treated me the wax with all the
women
fresh I know you haven't spoken once but
laugh stupid
bro I just want to make one point so if
I'm on Instagram and I'm getting 40 DMS
and you're getting 20 DMS my point is
that you guys are more likely to respond
to the 20 DMS than we are to the 40 DMs
here's the thing men and women are not
the same
[Applause]
and then on top of that men of status
men that are attractive that uh have uh
money hey it's just exercising options
I'm sorry so you're actually saying that
in a relationship it's okay for men to
go and explore other options but we have
to be happy with you and not explore
options
absolutely close on your end open on my
end and I think this should be honest
between the two yeah
you can't just get throwing that thing
around and women sit at home waiting for
you to come home don't need to smell the
juice of another woman on you here's the
thing here's the thing can all men get
away with this absolutely not a small
minority of men can but the reality is
since the beginning of time strong
powerful men right that had money and
Status were always able to have hordes
of women look at you Hefner look at that
bless Aaron look at Kings look at
Sultans of past with this this is what
women do women are attracted to men but
it is me bro I suppose I spoke today I
spoke to Dan I spoke to Dan Bilzerian
I'm sick of you asking to finish your
long boring win we're answers that are
the same answer every time we ask you a
question even Dan Bilzerian last week
told me to my face yeah so [ __ ] what
clown here you are on the show I can
turn you off as well just turn these
clowns off see you fellas grow up bring
us back when you're 30 and you've got
half a brain you're not running around
being led by your own dicks
well Jesus Christ now these guys I
didn't mind having them on yes we asked
them to come on the show yes we asked
them their opinion this [ __ ] over
there he just keeps going men and women
are different I know I can dig I convert
who I want a woman should just do what I
say no grow up bro grow up even Dan
Bilzerian said he's so lonely because
the rooting around and the parties are
fun but the guy's lonely watching this
to me it's like a
there's two things the first layer which
is
we hate these [ __ ] because they corny
yeah and everybody jumped on that
because they're very detestable yeah
uncharismatic
but there's the layer behind it was like
what Fosters the people who love and
support them and what Fosters the people
who love and support the other side
because what do they mirror in each
other and what does that say about it
Society because what they feed of what
they feed into people
the hurt of people the same way that
Derek Jackson did that thing too he did
the same thing before for a woman he
catered to women they catered to men
that are hurt which is fine but they
just
you know when someone you once told me
that
there's some people that's going to take
profit of your pain
it's worth it for you to be in pain and
to stay there you know for pharmacists
pharmaceutical company you getting
healed is just one less client not
patient even though this whole rhetoric
is just pointless like this whole talk
about like super rich man's like who
cares what these guys are doing who
cares how they live let's tell the dream
who cares what their standards are she's
selling a dream you know you're like
you're not gonna live that life so who
cares she's selling a dream right and
people want that right like
the hyper focus on that is just funny to
me
on the other side
I think there are other talks in regards
to like you know realities of dating and
how it's like unfair to men speaks to
reality that a lot of men face that it's
tough out there for them to date and so
they identify with somebody who speaks
to them and speaks crudely and then also
speaks to the people who cause them hurt
you get what I'm saying because a lot of
dudes get [ __ ] over by women what a
lot of dudes feel like women are the
reason why they get hurt right and so
I could understand the appeal in that
regards because like nobody really talks
to women in a way that says like man
[ __ ] you and a lot of people feel that
way yeah right [ __ ] the same way this
way there's a lot of like like women who
feel like yo [ __ ] you dudes because like
some dudes cat called or whatever so
then they start talking about like men
are trash use the other side of that
coin yeah right so
me personally watching a lot of this
stuff
it's like
metal trash is like the 2022 version of
like the Modern Woman
meaning like when they say the Modern
Woman
they're basically saying women are trash
that's what they say
I agree I didn't say [ __ ] right when
they say like men are trash
when they say the Modern Woman is always
like man the Modern Woman is
unreasonable
like 2 days 2 that do that everybody's
like man a lot of women are like this
it's like this trend on Tick Tock yeah
tell me women are trashed without saying
that women are trash ugh
modern day more than modern day woman is
just ugh
and you realize there's just two sides
the same coin same thing yeah and what
is the product of the other
like they they coexist they they feed
each other yeah
yeah
I definitely see that I definitely say I
feel like I feel like everyone's just
operating from a place to like man my
experience with the opposite gender
haven't been good and there's things in
society that are real that are unfair
and I'm living that and I've lived that
and I'm mad
and the other side is the reason for
that I think that's for a lot of things
yes it's a lot easier to talk about
others it's like for most issues I agree
because introspection or looking at
yourself and then having a self-improved
is always a lot more difficult
definitely than pointing out the fingers
yes and it's also a lot more profitable
because you get to feed off people's
hate yeah right
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below what do you guys think
about the interview some of the stuff
that we said all this other stuff let's
not
I'll let you talk most on the video
because I didn't want to you know get
you off